Hi, and welcome to the third office hours.
We've got, again, more good questions.
Let's get right at them. &gt;&gt;All right.
The first one comes from Voythos, and Voythos is taking CS262 as well with Wes Weimer.
In that class they talked about finding state machines as a representation
of the underlying engine for regular expressions.
In our implementation, is that actually what we did or did we do something different?
That's a great question.
We didn't explicitly show that, but there is a one-to-one correspondence between
a regular expression and a finite state machine.
And we can post some references, some supplementary material for that.
But you can make up a little table of here is a regular expression--
say the alt regular expression, a or b--and then here's a finite state machine.
I guess one way to implement that would be you'd have a start state,
you'd have two epsilon transitions to the a or b,
and then two epsilon transitions coming back.
So any regular expression corresponds one-to-one
to a little collection of nodes in the finite state machine.
That means you can go in either direction.
Does that mean that we've actually implemented that?
Well, it kind of depends on how you look at it.
Yes, you could say that we've implemented it, because you can show what they look like,
but we aren't really creating objects that correspond to these individual states.
They're sort of existing ephemerally when we execute the program
rather than being defined exactly ahead of time.
In that sense, no.
I guess, maybe in the more important sense, the types of manipulations we can do
with what we implemented are slightly different than what you would do
if you explicitly created these finite state machines--
particularly this transition between deterministic and nondeterministic machines.
That's a little hard to do exactly in the representation that we had,
although you could do something very much like it by starting to memoize your functions and so on.
You could arrive at the same place as you would by doing that transition with machines.
Great. If you want an in depth discussion on finite state machines,
you can check out the link below this video to Wes's course.